thanks everyone so it's great to be here
so I'm going to talk about models
interpretability so so there was this
question in the title presentation can
you trust neural networks so how many of
you think that you can trust neural
networks can you raise a hand and not so
much so maybe my presentation is not so
important actually
so I'm machine learning technique and
that guru and we are building very
quickly a new team and we are doing
computer vision and LP and and some
recommender systems and a lot of stuff
actually and if you're more interested
you can catch me later yeah and so let's
move on to the to the topic of the
presentation so I would like to start
with a question
let's imagine that you have you can you
have opportunity to go to the AI doctor
who is 80% accurate and can explain its
diagnosis or a eye doctor who is 90%
accurate but cannot so which one do you
pick so if you kept if you could raise
the hand for the first one for 80% with
explanation okay and for the second yes
so I guess most of people believes in
explanations great so short agenda so
the first thing is motivation why
explaining neural networks predictions
there or any other model predictions are
important and then I'm going to talk
about lime and shop those are two
frameworks for explaining machine
learning models so let's start with his
basic who is going to a bank to get a
loan and there is machine learning model
which is deciding whether the bishop can
get a loan and machine learning models
claims that there is 55% that his bishop
is not going to be able to pay the loan
and he his got declined and Bishop asks
why it's important for him to understand
this and it's important for his
customers satisfaction but also banks
wants to know why
because you know like the model might be
wrong and it's about the profit of the
bank but the customer satisfaction is
also important for the bank so they are
going to the data scientist and data
scientists as deep learning a magic yeah
so that's the common issue with models
like neural networks or or complex
decision trees like eg boost that the
complex models are tend to be accurate
but tend to be at the same time not
easily interpretable why the simple
models are interpretable but not usually
not always have the same level of
accuracy as the complex models and you
can see the trade-off between the
customer satisfaction in this case like
in model interpretability
and the profits for the bank like
accuracy of actually predicting whether
the shock is going to be to be able to
pay the loan or not and the next
motivation it's actually from my life
why I why actually I'm interested in in
explaining machine learning predictions
machine learning models prediction so so
for last three years I worked on Street
to shop image search engine so on the
input we had some image like with some
actresses or or just from the some shops
and the output should be the exact
clothing items or or similar ones and
the part of those whole system was a
shoe kind classifier so we were going so
we are predicting soccer shoes boots
high skills ballerinas and and some
other kinds and our training procedure
was quite Commons quite standard we we
splitted our training set our data set
into the training set validation and
test set there were 16 classes of those
shoe skeins and we had 10,000 images per
class which is quite ok
we measured performance with a curiosity
because the data set was balanced and we
did transfer learning of resin at 15
kapha at the time and we got a curiosity
like 90 90 foot per
% so can we trust this number and I can
imagine after your first responses that
probably wouldn't be so sure and yeah
let's see a couple of predictions so so
we have soccer shoes and we have high
fields and it works we have some boots
and sneakers and then we have some
predictions on on high heels
soccer shoes and on sneakers I guess
still soccer shoes so what's wrong here
so what do you think what's what's wrong
with this classifier do you have any
ideas ruff yeah so exactly if we
visualize the parts of the image that
were that were crucial to to decide
whether it's high-heeled or soccer shoes
it occurred that the classifier look at
the grass so how can we gain trust in
machine learning models so the first
thing is a curiosity and other metrics
like precision recall or f1 score but
actually if we if we have the different
test data distribution that the training
data distribution which is not always
very easy to to client it to track it
might lie to us so the other thing is a
be testing model on production but it's
expensive and we may expose the user to
the poorly performed performing model
the next thing is obviously experience
if we have very experienced machine
learning engineers they probably can
catch those things quicker than later
but at the end there is interpretability
so actually understanding why our model
is doing such predictions so how do we
define what do I mean by
interpretability here so in this talk
I'm talking only about local
interpretability so on the level of
single example explanation which means
that for a given input example and now
two prediction we assign some important
score to the part of the input and what
our good explanation trades
so the first its it should be somehow
aligned to human intuition so like in
this case of the grass
if the explanation would be correct and
aligned to human intuition then we
probably should have visualized some
parts of high heels and especially
probably heel the other thing it should
be faithful to regional model it means
that the model which is explaining the
complex model for a given input should
have the same prediction as a complex
model and the other thing would be great
if we have some model for explaining
which is model agnostic and can explain
decision trees SVM's and neural networks
in any other model and it might be
difficult but actually there are already
couple of frameworks which are tackling
this problem so so let's talk about the
first first one the and it's called lime
which stands for local interpretable
model agnostic explanations and lime has
two key ideas so let's we imagine a
classification case with just two
classes and we have some complex model
that is doing predictions on this data
set and we'll pick a simple model which
is interpretable by few months like
linear model and we do the prediction
for for with this linear model for a
given specific case and this in your
model locality is very good you can see
that this we have good decision boundary
for this green example but this decision
model would be very poor in in other
places of this area so how does lime
actually work so with sample data points
which are close to the input example by
some perturbations to the input example
and soon will so soon we will see how it
exactly works on images but let's just
imagine that we sample some data points
which are close in some metric then we
use this complex model to generate
predictions for all those points those
sample data points wrong way are
weighted by some distance to the input
and then we train simple model like
linear regression on those weighted
sample
to predict some feature importance
values so there are basically the ways
of linear regression so on the
particular example of images so this so
we have this input image on the left and
we do super super pixel segmentation
with quick shift algorithm and then to
generate close to the input image
samples we do perturbations by randomly
covering some super pixels and those are
our training examples and we do the
prediction for a given label with this
complex model so the given label here is
Labrador and on those perturbative
examples we train linear regression and
exactly in line case is Kayla Tsering
regression which shrinks featuring
weighted which shrinks parameters of the
regression to zero if if the features
are not important for for a prediction
and at the end we can visualize only
those super pixels which has high by
high value of the of the weights of
linear regression so we can see that the
most important part of of this input
image to predict Euler brother was
actually this dog face and for some
reason some part on the bottom so you
can see that's not perfect
yeah so from the matic mathematical
standpoint lime tries to minimize some
loss function over a class of
interpretable models G so those are
let's say linear models
and he uses kernel for weighting samples
which is this distance kernel and the
lime has some heuristic to choose this
kernel which is exponential function and
we have also this parameter of
regularization so you can imagine that
this kernel which is just chose by by
hand probably it's not perfect and we
can smoothly go to shop which allows us
to choose better this kernel
so if we take the step back in general
lime its we have some data and the lime
is working like we targeting some parts
of the data so in this case we toggled
x1 off and we do the prediction and we
observe change in the prediction and we
can also toggle a subset of of the
features and we can observe the change
in the prediction and observing those
changes we would like to somehow
summarize the effect of changes on the
prediction and we summarize this
computing featuring pointers values that
we attribute to the model so basically
we have some features on the input and
our our converted input are just ones
and zeros that are stating whether some
input is on or off so we can replace
this model with simple sum with just
some of those feature importance
attributes and actually line can be
expressed in this way also and here is
interesting connection to the game
theory so in 1953 there was some let's
say discover over the first paper
published on Shapley values and actually
there is only one way to assign those
feature important values if we assume 3
/ 3 properties for this function and
those properties are local accuracy so
this means that the model is faithful to
the complex model so basically for a
given input and converted input to ones
and zeros we have the same prediction
the second one is missingness so if some
feature is missing then there is no
impact on prediction and consistency and
consistency means that if we have two
models and we compare those two models
and if some feature makes a bigger
difference than tackling the feature in
the second model then importance of this
feature in the first model has to be
higher than in the second one so we have
those three simple properties
and then there is only one solution to
do this to achieve to obtain the feature
important values in general so how do we
compute those sharply additive values
also called chappie additive
explanations so let's get back to the
Fisher case be sure getting alone so
there was fifty five percent chance that
boishakh is not going to get along and
and not going to pay the loan so he's
going to be defined and we start with
expected value on our prediction of
complex model and it's 20 percent let's
say and how we did how how can we get to
the to the risk for basic so first weak
condition we start with this base rate
twenty percent and we conditioned this
on on some first feature which is H so
special is very young so it increases
the risk up to thirty five percent and
the other I think this bit shock is day
trader so his job is not stable and
increase the risk fervor up to seventy
percent and we can go with all the
features this way so the next thing is
how many open accounts Bishop has and
that he is married so maybe he's not
maybe he's part in class and maybe he's
working or whatever and at the end we
end up with fifty five percent but the
important things the order matters here
because you know like the importance of
day trader is high quite high because we
already know that he is young and maybe
the young day trader it's some someone
who who is not stable his in terms of
his budget and if we don't know that
he's young then it could happen that day
trader future importance might be lower
so to obtain actually the feature values
for sure for those job feature values we
need to average over all possible
configurations so there is n factorial
possible configurations it's not
refitted
and we can so the idea is to do some
approximations here and here here the
line comes actually so we connect we can
connect the lime with shop and actually
if we force local accuracy and
consistency there is a proof that we can
compute the loss function the
regularizer and the kernel for a lime
directly and we can use just lime to to
obtain Shapley values so why actually
this whole thing about Shapley values
that we can be if we can only use if we
can just use lime why those Shapley
virus are important and the main reason
behind this is actually that Shapley
various empirically it's proven
empirically so it's not really prevent
vertically but it observe it it is
observed empirically that sharply values
improve consistent consistent with human
intuition so let's take this back again
and we have some data like whether he
has a cough or fewer or congestion I
don't have some treatment model for some
education that works well on the early
stage of disease and it's not so
important later and the model outputs
treatment priority for the shack so so
we have those rules that's if if we have
cough or fewer than the priority is 5 if
we have both there's two otherwise it's
zero and let's see the check has both
coffee and fewer so the treatment
priority by the model is two and we are
interested was the feature importance
for CAF and was the feature importance
for fewer so so we can do those
explanations with lime and we can do
those explanations with sharply but to
compare with human intuition we actually
need to go to Amazon Mechanical Turk
prepare some tasks for for humans and
let humans decide what's the influence
of those features and the outers of
paper actually did
kind of experiment and they achieve some
feature importance values that were
stated by humans and actually the future
importance values which are generated by
shop were very similar and byline were
quite much different so this is the
reasoning behind using actually shop in
combination with flying the other
important things we can actually define
a lot of models that are trying to
explain neural networks or decision
trees the models like deep lift or
relevance propagation in the same manner
like shop t-virus so shopping buyers are
actually unifying framework for those
models so I have this question again
which doctor would you choose so already
a lot of people chose at the Benini
at the beginning the the model with
explanation but let's see whether it
changed so who would choose the 90%
accurate without explanation so I guess
it's still it's even less than in the
beginning so so the question comes
actually from the Twitter from the Pedro
Domingues who wrote the master algorithm
buck and and he actually stated this
question and and he said that he would
choose the 90 percent because he doesn't
care about explanation if he's going to
die yeah I would do the same I guess
but I built that explanations are very
important to actually improve machine
learning models not necessary to to
explain to the end user but so see
important is also important from the
legal issues especially since GDP are
the other thing about the explanations I
don't know if you heard but probably
heard about the net fixed price and
Netflix uses recommender system for the
movies and actually the complex model
which was an explainable performed for
Netflix is worse than the model which
was explainable and user users of the
Netflix could see actually explain
why those particular movies are
suggested to them so I would like to
finish with the quote from Richard
Feynman that if you cannot explain
something in simple terms you just don't
understand it as also saw her motivation
behind working on in this specific area
of machine learning which is I think
those explanations are very young but
it's rising field so I have some credits
to the outers of papers and all the
materials I used to prepare the
presentation and that's all from me and
thankful thank you so much matters we
have a time of a few questions I think
thanks for I actually enjoyed the
presentation enjoyed a lot so but I have
some questions regarding sharply values
I have noticed that some phenomenon some
phenomena in lime for example when you
use large let's imagine a simple case
you are trying to explain the decision
tree or very simple of trees and you try
to explain something that's beyond the
borders of your training set so it kind
of played the plateaus over there and
when you extract an explanation
it gives you all zeros and it's supposed
to because there is no variation locally
does chapli deal with this because you
need to reinterpret how you deal with
explanations with machine learning
explanations in this case this so the
question is how do how does sharply deal
with things beyond the range of your
known known data yeah let's say I think
it doesn't deal with it but I'm not sure
I thank you for the very nice talk I
have one question in one comment the
question is how is this different from
let's say random forest classifier or
some other kind of ensemble methods the
whole thing about using a simplified
model and then averaging over multiple
ones
them and optimizing that so that's the
question and the comment is about the
last slide about fragments code and if
you can't explain something in simple
terms you don't understand it
maybe he also probably made it in
relation to quantum mechanics but the
thing is the explanation the thing that
you pointed out is it should match with
human intuition and we know now from all
the experiments in quantum mechanics is
the explanations never matched the human
intuition so is it very essential that
the explanation that the model comes up
matches with your intuition it could be
something very bizarre but still somehow
logical so it's just a comment but the
first part is what's different between
ensemble approaches and this yeah that's
very cool comment I like it okay so I
think that's you know like in some
approaches or random forests you can't
really interpret them I mean like you
can interpret simple decision trees like
shallow but if you go with big deaf then
then it's not really interpreter before
human so that's the reason for me to use
just the linear models I don't know was
it is it the core of the question
or did that makes more sense because
maybe in this ensemble metals you have
two simple and shallow but in your
method you're telling me that you can go
for much more complicated architectures
but still have some explained ability
yeah because there are two models
basically always you know like you have
the complex model like random forest
let's say random for us or neural
network and the other models just need a
regression and you have those two models
are tied in this way that so we have the
input like image for the complex model
and the input for the simple model is
just you know like ones and zeroes which
are correspond to specific several
pixels in the image and we do the linear
regression and yeah and we can interpret
them in your model easily so so we just
you know like they are tight all the
time and we explaining of the simple
model the the complex model
you just like focusing on the part of
the data which was used to make
decisions yeah yeah so it's similar like
with if if we go with text and we have
bag of words representation so the input
for the simple model it's not big of
words but it's also you know like the
vector of zeros and ones short one so
correlator features for example in the
banking example if you have age and
years of experience of working
experience how would which model the
model would pick which feature to
explain because the the features are
correlated you see how do these models
work with this kind of particularity
yeah okay that's interesting question I
think in case of shop because we are
going so in the general case when we are
going over all configurations then those
feature importance I think that would be
similar for both of them
not sure how this approximation would
work but I I think it will be similar ok
thank you so much for those great
recipes thanks a lot